let's jump to this story from
timcast.com because I want to make fun
of Joe Biden Biden responds to
handwritten letter from Child about
gender pay gap on equal payday men are
getting more money than girls I think
you should fix this since you were the
president
um this is written by Christopher
Bertman and I'm going to issue a fact
check here uh Biden did not respond to a
handwritten letter from a child because
I do not believe they ever actually
stated it was from a child nor does it
appear to actually be from a child let
me show you the tweet in question and
then we'll go through some standard
journalistic ethics Joe Biden tweeted
Charlotte I couldn't agree more women
lose thousands of dollars each year and
hundreds of thousands over over a
lifetime because of gender and racial
wage gaps I'm committed to building an
economy where my daughters have the same
rights and opportunities as my sons
so nowhere in here does it say this
letter was written by a child that's the
first and foremost thing that
timcast.com needs to correct the
headline says from Child we don't know
that alleged child no there's no alleged
at all we'd add that no no no where in
Biden Suite does it say it's from a
child
it doesn't that way when the Letter's
fake they can say like oh we never said
it was from a child this is just from
Charlotte who has terrible hands that's
right it's it's from Charlotte who has
terrible handwriting it the letter says
Dear President Biden it's about wrong I
just wanted to tell you to to tell
something not fair to ladies men are
getting more money notice the cursive G
this is not written by a child John
fetterman more money than girls I think
you should fix this since you're the
Press attent even I'm a child and I
think we should do something
from Charlotte there's like four
different kinds of handwriting in that
too but most importantly notice the G's
are written in cursive the G's are
written by someone who know who who has
got uh they haven't taught cursive in
like 20 years and not only that they
don't teach it to Children this young so
a child who is writing who is writing uh
is printing what do you call like I
don't know cursive and then what
standard or printing printing then they
wouldn't be using stylized G's like this
right so first and foremost
no sane human being thinks a child wrote
Joe Biden this letter if you do I'm
sorry but you will need some help all
right especially as you get older and
maybe maybe you should wear a helmet
but the funny thing is let's just talk
about the actual message from President
Biden there's no gender wage Gap
there it is we know it everybody knows
it and I think this is a great litmus
test for
um isn't it been like 10 years since
that's been debunked it's been debunked
since they faked they lied and made it
up like it's never been true when
corrected for jobs and and tenure and
all those kind of things it's like a
penny
it's it's I think it's between three and
seven percent and that is actually uh
explained for in many academic studies
for men's desire to negotiate in women's
lack of desire to negotiate
women tend to be more agreeable and this
is the scientific literature that when a
guy goes to a job he says I want a job
and they say we'll give you 50k he goes
give me 60 and they go we'll give you 55
and he goes deal the moon walks in and
she goes I want a job to say 15 she goes
well okay I guess
but that's that's a fact so that ends up
with man getting slightly more but this
is nothing to do with discrimination it
is a function of human behavior period
and it's sociology is not allowed to be
used the only I have to clarify that my
wife buys cars for us because she's not
that chick all right she makes him cry
and I think that's a different thing but
that's not common and you don't do it on
on abnormalities like that look at this
look at this a in the letter that's
written in this weird way like a loop
and then this a right here that's litten
written written differently so I think
they had four
gen Z people collaborating on this to
help Biden get a letter from a kid I
think the G is the most revealed Legend
also what's like blurred under Charles
the address I guess
yeah there's also like the devil is
there yes I love writing do you guys
ever heard of that underneath it says
age 47.
from the Department oh yeah the interior
P.S I've been something something yeah
it says PS
I've been blank so this is not like I've
been paid to write this yeah I've been
paid then check PS send help yeah first
of all nobody writes letters when was
the last time someone wrote a letter yes
all the time because yo that g is legit
weird they start from the middle do a
loop around down and then back and up
I don't see a child making a g like that
that's a complicated G
you know I'm like I'm like how do you
how do you write it Charlotte's AI you
go top and around and down you don't go
down around and then loop back
also even if this was a real child like
I feel bad for this kid whose parents
have clearly put them up to their
political bidding right like not a child
about this but if it were hypothetically
if it were I know it's probably not I
know this person is probably not even
real and a team of graphic designers put
this together for a nice tweet from
Biden but that was chat GPT oh my gosh
probably oh look at the ID Twitter users
criticize the president's post so I you
know apologies to our writer Tim cast
yes a four-year-old girl named Charlotte
is writing the president letters about
her concern with a gender pay grap wrote
One user Alex I'll take stuff that never
happened for 800.
which one of your staff named Charlotte
ask another user and that could have
been kjp so I was just probably closer
we did include this in here it appeared
to be inauthentic and manufactured
that's right it is it's not real I'm
sorry but the pay Gap and the letter
manufactured both the topic and the
story well you know kjp is really bad
she gives diversity hiring a bad name
you know what was the the lady that that
she replaced what was the other gen sake
yeah she was she was like he was a loser
but she was good at being yeah oh yeah
she was very horrendously good she did
her job well kjp is an embarrassment
there's so many times where she just is
so incredibly unprepared to discuss
whatever the topic is and it's
embarrassing remember remember when that
she gets asked about Marianne Williamson
running for president and she goes well
if I had a um uh you know a globe or a
look to look in the future and someone
goes on crystal block yeah yeah crystal
ball so a globe she has this moment does
she think that people pull up Globes and
then scry into them whatever the spear
thing is she'll have these moments where
she like is looking she's a pen her hand
she blinks several times and then she
keeps going like she has all these
physical manifestations of her Confusion
And Delay and like if she weren't so
terrible I would feel bad for her it's
even worse when she's reading and can't
manage to read her prepared script in a
coherent fashion I'm like come on okay I
do have to get you a correction the
letter does say even I'm a child but
like Fair Point fair point I missed that
I mean I just yeah bring Chris Bertman
right now my point is this no sane
person legitimately thinks a child wrote
this letter
handwriting and I've sent this in
Charlotte is probably her newborn infant
Charlotte's mom and her Wine Group
wine put that letter together that
sounds like some Aussie spumanti and a
terrible idea
I'm just gonna I'm gonna go and say it I
I'm looking at the handwriting and
outright
none of this writing style is how they
teach people to write so for a child let
me point out a few things that make
literally no sense if you look at the D
right here you can see it starts on the
top and goes down and then jumps around
that's not how they teach kids to write
D's you start with the loop and go up
then down and back and then you can
notice the G as I already pointed out it
starts from here and then loops around
and then goes back and then you look at
the uppercase D from the bottom up and
out that's not how they teach kids to
write D's either this is written by
someone who's gone to college and and
and developed a writing style after
years and that and and also I have to be
honest it may even be written by more
than one person as you guys pointed out
because some of the handwriting looks
completely different I'd love to
actually get like you know they do those
forensic handwriting people to like look
at this and be like oh yeah that's a 35
year old woman tomorrow we'll get that
somebody because somebody listening
that's the great thing about the
internet if someone is looking at it
right now they're gonna make a video
like something W on like the second to
last line is more curved than the one at
the top there's different sizes they're
different pressures on the paper yeah I
mean why would they write precedent yeah
like they understand they know what
Biden is but not president
like it's just it's like when they make
them R backwards to make it seem like a
kid wrote it oh here you take a look at
this in the word something the G is
written with starting from the middle
and going back and then down but then
the other G's are written in a very
different way this is written by
multiple people I think we should have
multiple children recreate this letter
just like
that would be funny we just go to a drag
show and have the kids we'll pass around
a piece of paper there you go
I know where we can find kids
help me my mom took me to a drag show
she's handy there you go dollar bills
Robbie Starbucks says Charlotte has
another letter for you and she makes a
lot of sense in this one dear President
Biden I just wanted to tell you
something not fair to America Ukraine is
getting more money than homeless
veterans or broken roads our border
security and my parents combined I think
you should fix this and stop giving tax
dollars to them I'm a child and even I
know what you're doing is stupid from
Charlotte P.S please don't pretend boys
are girls anymore it sounds crazy
Robbie and Landon his wife helped get a
bill passed against this kind of crazed
Trends stuff for kids in Tennessee so
kudos to Robbie and Landon on that they
did great work
that g is driving me nuts they're
different but it's just like it's the
most pretentious G ever
she thinks it's getting away with this
yeah I'm just I'm sitting in my notepad
I'm I'm I'm looking at how they made the
G and I'm like what what is this she is
taunting you yeah they wrote it one step
it was once again from a ransom note cut
out of the magazine
calligraphy like they couldn't they
couldn't help but just like every letter
has to be busted up and weird looking
but the G they couldn't help but they're
like I have to put my Twirl in it do you
think that person has a g in their name
and they're used to it therefore writing
the G yeah
who did this
I don't know Joe Biden's a liar this is
so I think this is probably like how she
spelled her name here's here's the thing
Biden supporters
look this letter purpose perfectly
exemplifies the difference between
Pro Biden and not pro Biden because
there are people who don't like Trump
but don't like Biden
the the Democrat people who think the
economy is good right now are the people
who think this is a real letter there
there's an overlap between the cognitive
abilities of the of the part the average
person who likes Biden and everyone else
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time